la grande inconnue de ces jeux reste la
sécurité et la menace pourrait bien
venir de la rebellion islamique
tchétchène que la russie n'a jamais
réussi à éradiquer
même après deux guerres dans la petite
république du caucase
cette insurrection elle s'est maintenant
déplacée au daguestan voisin et son chef
a demandé à ses combattants de tout
faire pour perturber les jeux la
tchétchénie elle qui se trouve à
quelques centaines de kilomètres à peine
de sotchi semble aujourd'hui pacifiée sa
capitale a été reconstruite mais à quel
prix
pour comprendre cette autre facette du
régime de vladimir poutine
je suis retourné en tchétchénie avec la
réalisatrice francine doyon
la ville de grozny s'est donné des airs
de dubaï un décor surréaliste où l'islam
domine avec en plein coeur une mosquée
qui rivalise avec les plus grandes
d'europe et ces femmes à qui on a imposé
le voile couvertes de la tête aux pieds
qui défilent dans toute leur splendeur
mais il y à l'envers du décor et il a
osé biscayne est longue et j'ai perdu
des êtres chers et je vais poursuivre le
combat en leur mémoire je dois le faire
s'il me tue quelqu'un d'autre prendra ma
place
ils ne peuvent pas tuer tout le monde on
en mange de la pop typique
nous avons eu régimes autoritaires n'ont
pas totalitaire mais bien autoritaire il
n'y a pas de constitution ici ni de
l'oise pendant cinq ans
le cauchemar tchétchène commence en 1994
la russie refuse l'indépendance de la
petite république du caucase
de petites unités de combattants
tchétchènes toute la ville maintenant et
dans cet état là j'ai été témoin de la
guerre un conflit qui a duré des années
et qui a fait plus de cent mille morts
les rebelles indépendantistes sont
vaincus j'admire poutine confiera
finalement le pouvoir aux tchétchène
ramzan kadirov
à 37 ans il dirige toujours la
république comme bon lui semble
il a sa propre milice il a son au
personnel de grandes vedettes
internationales viennent à ses frais
célébrer son anniversaire alors le
monsieur cameron
il a même offert un appartement au
comédien français gérard depardieu
avec les milliards qu'il reçoit de
moscou pour pacifier la région
kadyrov s'est construit une capitale à
son image il a voulu effacer toutes les
traces de la guerre coûte que coûte le
nombre de violations des droits de la
personne est tout simplement ahurissant
des centaines d'innocents ont été
assassinées ou torturées
bien sûr dans l'eau il y avait quelques
terroristes mais monsieur kadirov à
régler le problème de façon presse
anglaise et monsieur poutine a fermé les
yeux et pour notre part nous oleg habib
rakhmanov et russes c'est un des avocats
du jet mobilegov où l'un des derniers
remparts contre ces atrocités
le bureau est muni de caméras de
surveillance et pour éviter de devenir
une cible
il ne passe jamais plus d'un mois en
tchétchénie quant à la liste était
longue ligne c'est difficile pour nous
de savoir si c'est un terroriste ou pas
ou du stage a été mise à clignoter
monsieur khadir avait monsieur poutine
parle de détruire ce qui veut dire de
tuer tous les suspects que ce soit des
terrorisme ou non c'est illégal
aida sarah thauvin milite elle aussi
depuis des années pour les droits de la
personne elle nous a donné rendez vous
dans un appartement d'emprunt la
pression est forte aujourd'hui elle a dû
se joindre un groupe de travail du
gouvernement
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
travailler aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque de
la guerre d'abord autrefois on savait
qu'il était notre ennemi sur le
moins-disant de sir paul
il y encore des arrestations arbitraires
d'après nos sources les enquêteurs
utilisent encore les tortures au fil des
ans
l'insurrection s'est déplacé dans les
montagnes tchétchène et dans les
républiques voisines elle c'est
islamisée et radicalisée revendiquant
des attentats meurtriers à moscou et
ailleurs en russie dans le caucase du
nord
les incidents sont presque quotidiens et
tous les prétextes sont bons pour
poursuivre la réflexion
oleg mène toujours ces enquêtes pour que
les victimes tchétchène cette justice
nous allons vous présenter des gens qui
connaissent la vraie tchétchénie liège
nous l'accompagnons à travers la ville
la plupart des gens ont peur de parler
il nous amène voir une des rares
familles qui a accepté de nous
rencontrer
sous le bec à marie-eve et son épouse
rosa ont deux fils le plus jeune mourad
a été arrêté l'été dernier il était
soupçonné le connaître une personne qui
aurait placé des explosifs sous la
voiture d'un chef de police mourad a été
torturé mais il a tout ni après quelques
jours il a été libéré d'office étaient
sur le seuil de la porte
il avait été battu il était couvert de
bleus ses bras étaient en c1 est privée
de lewa taux n'a pas droit où ils l'ont
amené dans une cave qui l'ont bâillonné
ils ont ligoté ils ont battu mes achats
les hameaux ils ont pendu par les pieds
ils l'ont battu et torturé avec de
l'électricité bas pottas le top 20 et
est bien sûr c'est difficile tellement
difficile je n'ai pas élevé mes garçons
pour en arriver là rohff préhistoire
s'accapare gorée à son programme les way
ce qu'ils décrivent n'est pas rare il ya
de nombreux cas d'enlèvement et quand
ces gens reviennent ils disent qu'ils
ont été torturés mais il ya encore plus
de gens qui ne reviennent jamais leurs
familles ne savent même pas s'ils sont
morts ou vivants
mourad vit maintenant en sécurité en
ukraine et soul ou beckham rêve a décidé
avec l'appui de legs de porter plainte
c'est très difficile de trouver et de
punir les coupables
tout le monde a peur les enquêteurs les
gens ordinaires
les journalistes et les défenseurs des
droits de la personne yproise chimiques
bayat
tout le monde me dit que ce que ramzan
kadyrov veut bien entendre
les représailles peuvent être mortels
une collègue d'eads à natalia estemirova
était très critique des autorités
elle a été retrouvé le corps criblé de
balles en 2001 il était le coeur de
notre combat continu animaux et natacha
ici mais je sais sur quel cas il
travaillait et pourquoi mais il a été
assassiné
il est 4e à 1 point des bois et si vous
deviez disciples un stade
j'aurais honte de partis et de vivre
ailleurs nous les vrais héros sont ici
et je suis très soulagé rouergue wii et
ses jours
officiellement le conflit est terminé
mais la paix peut parfois être aussi
terrible que la guerre
comme certains disent ici tout est calme
aujourd'hui la tchétchénie est
silencieuse comme un cimetière